one of my direct subordinates one of my
guys that worked for me he would he
would call me up or pull me aside with
some major problem some issue that was
going on and he'd say possibly got this
and that and the other thing and I look
at him I'd say good and finally one day
he was telling me about some issue that
he was having some problem and he said I
already know what you're gonna say I
said well what am I going to say he said
you're gonna say good he said that's
what you always say when something is
wrong and going bad you always just look
at me and say good and I said well yeah
when things are going bad there's going
to be some good that's going to come
from it didn't get the new high-speed
gear we wanted good didn't get promoted
your time you get
Oh mission got cancelled good we can
focus on the other one didn't get funded
didn't get the job you wanted got
injured sprained my ankle got tapped out
good got be
unexpected problems good
we have the opportunity
to figure out a solution that's it when
things are going bad don't get all
bummed out don't get startled don't get
frustrated
you
if you can say the word good
means you're still alive
it means you're still bleeding
and if you're still breathing
or now you still got some fight left in
you so get up dust off reload
recalibrate re-engage go out on the
attack
you